des collègues en deuil après
l'assassinat du journaliste Arman
dolinares c'était le 8ème journaliste
assassiné au Mexique en 2022 un record
et ceci malgré les protections accordées
par l'État mexicain au journaliste
menacés les journalistes les
communicadoce qui travaille sur des
sujets soit liés à la politique locale à
la corruption et des sujets droits de
l'homme à l'environnement
sont très très vulnérables à des
situations de violence la moitié des
journalistes assassinés dans le monde
était latino américain 11 journalistes
mexicain tué en 2022 c'est la quatrième
année consécutive où le Mexique et le
pays le plus meurtrier au monde trois
suspects dans l'assassinat d'armane
dolinares ont été arrêtés c'est rare au
Mexique le gouvernement va tout mettre
en oeuvre pour
identifier les responsables on est à
plus de 100 cas de gens les sués au
Mexique sur les sur les dernières 10 ans
le président Andress manuel Lopes
Obrador au pouvoir depuis plus de 4 ans
veut protéger les journalistes
il a donné plus de 1000 conférences de
presse matinale la magnanera la
grand-messe quotidienne il va discuter
des gros sujets de l'ordre du jour
ouvertement avec les journalistes
présents mais il va profiter aussi de
ses conférences de presse pour attaquer
certains médias pour accuser un
journaliste spécifiquement nominalement
d'être en train de faire des fake news
résultat de l'hostilité de la part des
partisans du président Mexicains qui
vont mobiliser des insultes des attaques
sur les réseaux sociaux contre certains
journalistes certains médias les accusés
d'être en train de jouer heureux de
l'opposition etc parfois ces hostilités
peuvent même devenir des menaces
concrètes
alerte aussi au Guatemala ou le nouveau
gouvernement s'en prend aux journalistes
au Nicaragua aussi avec plus de 150
journalistes en exil au Costa Rica
qui continue comme ils peuvent à
diffuser de l'information vers leur pays
les manifestations au Pérou ont fait une
soixantaine de morts et des centaines de
blessés dont des journalistes prises à
partie
et enfin Haïti il y a une crise de
sécurité publique majeure en Haïti
depuis 2021 l'assassinat de l'ancien
président il y a une situation très très
complexe de sécurité en Haïti nous avons
vu l'année dernière si journaliste tu es
l'an dernier reporté à sans frontière
calculait que la presse se portait bien
dans un tiers des pays du monde les deux
tiers restants se classant pour moitié
de situation problématiques à situation
grave ou très grave ça ne devrait pas
beaucoup changer Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada Montréal